hey everybody i'm back with more chess
game breakdowns from the amazing report
assessing game balance with alpha zero exploring
different and new rules to chess it hit the press
more than a few days ago at this point from
google's deep mind and we've been bringing you
all the behind the scenes content we prepared so
it's time for a video on the big the big subject
i rank the idea of stalemate equaling a win as
my biggest takeaway it was number one on my top
10 list click the video in the notes below if you
missed it there's some things i think we should
consider from this report maybe instituting and
why not let's have some more fun and get more
decisive results now obviously the biggest con to
bringing bringing the fact that stalemate would
now equal a win is that we'd lose moments like
this from idiots on the internet who just simply
apparently don't know how to checkmate up a rook
and a bishop so yes if stalemate equaled a win
we would no longer have moments like that but
as we know the internet is full of idiots not
sure who that guy was doing crazy stuff so
if you're into watching people do dumb stuff
there's other things you can go watch on
the internet we don't need checkmate to be
a family anymore let everybody have a win with
stalemate uh and with this video i'm not gonna
just tell you why i think that's the case but
show you some positions that would totally change
uh the game but also some things that would have
to totally change in the approach by the world's
best chess players if stalemate equal to win
so without any further ado let's dive right
into why stalemate should be a win so we start
with the basics right king and pawn endings we
learned this in the beginning of our chess careers
because if we know how to win with just a single
extra pawn that gives us tons of empowerment in
the rest of the game now we value every piece
differently we we care about the tactics we have
this goal in our mind that all i really need is a
pawn to win because if i get it up to the edge
of the board a queen's gonna help me check me
the problem is that this particular position with
a more active king just a single more active king
from our opponent takes away all those dreams
all the dreams we have about a single pawn
helping us win a game we get to positions like
this and as i press play that's not the case
right that means all of our hard work the fact
that just a single pawn advantage that would
allow us to outplay our opponent for one trick
in the hopes that we get the end game that's
going to be a win with that pawn it's not a win
it's just a draw because as long as the king is
in front of a pawn those who know their king
and pawn opposition theory know that this is
a foregone conclusion black is going to keep the
king in front of the pawn and eventually achieve
equality by going straight back and then meeting
white with opposition and forcing stalemate this
is a theoretically known problem with the game if
you consider it a problem and as of this moment
i kind of do right so again why did i argue in my
breakdown that i think stalemate equaling a win
would do even more for human chess than alpha zero
this is one of the examples a single pawn is now
always a win not just this pawn but a corner pawn
is also a win because of stalemate equaling a win
right that would allow everything about the
earlier stages of the game how we evaluate and
assess those critical moments between magnus
carlsen and cara nakamura as having even
more weight because of that one pesh advantage
finally being enough here's my second example for
stalemate equaling a win talk about an advantage
you wish you could convert you got king and queen
versus king and pawn but guess what this is not a
win for those who know their theory because after
queen to b3 check black can play the move king
to a1 this is a well-known uh defensive trick
right you have to keep checking the king
forever because the moment you touch that pawn
stalemate well guess what if stalemate equals a
win that's no longer a problem right obviously
those defensive minded people in the comments
would be like defense isn't a problem anyway
obviously i'm aware of that but i'm giving
you an example of content that could lead to
more decisive results and i would argue again at a
human level not just alpha zero versus alpha zero
this could be a super exciting development right
the pressure it would add earlier in games because
you don't want to reach the same game anymore you
no longer get to assess the idea that you would
actually be able to hold a draw and rob all the
fans of that decisive result they want with the
biggest issue we have in the game of kings that a
draw is different than other sports it goes away
this is now a win for white because that trick
doesn't work and for those who don't know the trap
the moment the king goes in front of the pawn now
your king can come forward right you give checks
eventually you force the king back in front
this is very typical when the king's in front
you do it again you rinse and repeat eventually
checkmate it's only the idea of the stalemate that
allows this end game to be a draw but again as we
see maybe that's no longer a problem if stalemate
equals a win next position this is a funny
one because it actually changes the fact not
that zugzwang needs to exist because ziggs wong is
still a thing in a position where if someone could
say pass it would be a draw that would be more a
draw by agreement i almost would equate it to draw
by repetition or 50 moves zug's long is needed to
force someone to move when it's their turn right
in order for us to be able to win end games that
otherwise would not be winning if the turn didn't
have to pass in chess but this particular position
right here is actually normally a draw because in
this check the defensive technique is based around
stalemate the fact that white can't just wait here
because any move is a draw the king and bishop
no longer have squares that's a very confusing
concept for beginners to understand you have to
trap the king in order to checkmate just like the
king is trapped here the king has no moves when
he's checkmated just like the king has no moves
here surrounded by enemy pieces often just like
here right but no this is a draw the other ones
are a win again it would be very interesting to
see what human beings would have to do differently
right you couldn't even defend this engine anymore
by relying on the stalemate in the corner you'd
have to defend it with the king and the bishop
out in the wild right and what would that look
like i don't even i don't even know what it would
look like would this endgame still even be a draw
if you weren't able to rely on the stalemate
opposite color corner of your particular bishop
i don't know but it would be a lot of fun to
find out right my next position number four
talk about an end game that i've talked about with
grand master robert hess on every show we ever do
where grand masters are very smart and strategic
about defensing defending otherwise lost positions
by the fact that if you're in an opposite color
corner of the enemy bishop it's a draw this is a
stalemate despite the fact that white is up both
bishop and pawn well what if that wasn't the case
what if you can move forward and no longer fear
a move like bishop to f4 but rather embrace it
and win the game by stalemate right again
it's not even just about this position here
it would affect positions earlier in terms of
the level of play we'd have to see finding new
ways to maybe get a repetition in a draw
right the draw could still exist based on
the the idea that if you can check forever or
like we say get down to just king and king right
but there's no way that it doesn't increase a lot
of decisive results and add a lot of fun to how
we're evaluating more complicated positions case
in point how would we handle end games like this
where the fact that black played queen h2 check is
normally perfectly fine for a draw right because
as we already assessed earlier a pawn in front of
the king is an easily drawn king upon ending right
not if stalemate equals a win here white could
play queen e2 check a cross fire defensive and
aggressive move that punches us into the king and
pawn ending where suddenly white is winning with a
pawn that normally would not be enough right that
would mean queen h2 check is not a move that black
could afford having to rely on different diagonal
checks and trying to find more creative ways to
keep the game alive and keep the fans and viewers
happy now one of my last examples that i believe
is truly applicable at the very high levels
is rook endings so many rook endings are drawn
literally it is the pop culture phrase of whatever
russian grand master said it long ago all rook
endings are drawn i apologize for forgetting my
chess quotes for a second but it's been a long day
and this is like the fifth video i'm recording but
you've heard the thing all work endings are drawn
well this particular rook ending is a draw
because even though white has the king cut
off because the pawn is far advanced enough this
is known as a frontal attack the frontal attack
is a draw for black because you were able to keep
pressure on the pawn and then finally when your
king touched down on e8 the rook can go to e8 and
in a king and pawn ending this is an easy draw
again because the pawn is too advanced in front
of the king you simply use distant opposition
waiting for the king to come forward you just
wait on the eighth rank and the moment he does
you grab the opposition and you're going to
hold this draw as long as you know basic king
and pawn defensive principles but what if rookie 8
wasn't a possibility how do we assess this engine
suddenly we're looking at a rook ending
that's a theoretically known draw as
actually a win for white moves like rook c8 are
too slow the frontal attack defense here fails
when rookie 8 is off the table because the longer
you sit eventually okay we've already looked at
rookie being bad eventually we'll throw it
the white king comes up you check forever
i have a lot of videos on this end game over
on chess.com which would become irrelevant
if stalemate was a win right i'd have to redo
all my videos over their chess.com another good
reason to do this right for everyone who hates
those videos the point is eventually you check
that you get up the board and the rook has to
go back i.e the frontal attack and the moment
he does now the rook can come up next move you
attack the rook you attack the rook and you start
advancing and the black king is just too far away
the pawn and king outplay the rook this is known
as the frontal attack often it can be a defensive
measure that works but in this particular position
it wouldn't because black loses the advantage
he has that the king is protecting the idea
of breaking the white rook's control right this
defensive idea goes out the window and how many
other rook ending defensive ideas might go out
the window with it i have no idea all i know is
stalemate equaling a win would be something that
could change the way we we think about chess we
talk about chess we present chess to new beginners
and allow them to get the concepts of trapping an
enemy king much faster and even at the high levels
might really add entertainment and our different
viewpoint to how we look at all kinds of defensive
technique how we how we really emphasize smaller
advantages earlier now that we know we can't
just hold with stalemate i get excited about
the possibilities and i hope you do too leave a
comment down below don't leave me down leave a
comment give me a like come on we've worked hard
with this give us a share tell your friends about
me and these thesechest.com videos and again i
can't wait to hear your thoughts about whether i'm
totally crazy for ranking stalemate equals a win
above classical chess or whether you just might
you might hate yourself a little bit for
it but you might actually agree with me
on this one either way we will see you around on
chess.com and i can't wait to hear your thoughts